Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Daneko Cesarac. Ich bin heute die Dienstabende Erzitin hier
und würde jetzt gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja klar. Hauptsache irgendjemand hilft mir.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ja, ich habe solche Schmerzen in der Brust.
Puh, und das ist so plötzlich aufgetreten und
jetzt ist es zwar schon ein bisschen besser. Am Anfang war es ein ganz starker Schmerz, aber
Puh, sowas habe ich noch nicht gehabt und deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss,
ja, ich denke schon, das ist vielleicht allwähig gewesen, aber deswegen bin ich jetzt in die Notaufnahme gekommen.
Alles klar. Erstmal muss ich Ihre Name wissen. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Frank Winter.
Frank Winter. Können Sie bitte Ihre Namen buchen?
Ja, der Vorname ist Frank, F-R-A-N-K und Winter genauso wie Sommer, also W-I-N-T-E-R.
Okay, Herr Winter, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben eine Brust schmerzen.
Wann sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten? Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das ist vor zwei Stunden ist das losgegangen und ich kenne das schon, dass das mal so ein bisschen ist.
Wenn ich mich anstrenge, dann geht das aber so nach einer halben Stunde weg.
Und jetzt ist es zwar inzwischen erträglich, aber was eben anders war,
ist, ich habe mich überhaupt nicht angestrengt und trotzdem fing das mit einmal an
und es ist eben auch gar nicht besser geworden.
Alles klar. Wie könnten Sie diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzwelle einordnen, wobei nur keine umsehen und erträglich sind?
Also am Anfang war das bestimmt, also ja, über die Hälfte sechs.
Jetzt ist es nur noch so ein bisschen.
Ja, so.
Sechs.
Sechs von zehn.
Ja, also am Anfang sechs und jetzt ist es vielleicht noch so drei oder vier.
Drei, vier.
Ja, jetzt möchte ich diese Gespräche unterbrechen und erst mal sie eine,
wie schnell sie eine E-Karage schreiben und ihre Vitalparameter messen,
wie zum Beispiel Bruturupfus und Körpertemperatur.
Wenn alles in Ordnung sind, können wir...
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist, können wir diese anamäßige Sprech gleichzeitig weiterführen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Gut.
Sie haben das jetzt alles gemacht und es ist nichts, was jetzt ganz furchtbar ist, aber wir machen weiter, ja?
Okay.
Sechs und vier.
Herr Winter, können Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben, sie brennen, sie handdomen?
Also einmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass es ganz doll drückt und dann ist es aber auch ein Stechen der Schmerz.
Und ich fühle mich so eingeengt, als ob ich so einen Korsett umhabe, als ob irgendjemand mir den Brustkorb zuschnürt.
Ich trage diese Schmerzen in einen anderen Körperzeil aus.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, das geht so hier in den linken Arm rein.
Linken Arm.
Nur linken Arm oder linken Unterkiefer oder Händen.
Das habe ich ein bisschen, eigentlich nur im Arm habe ich bisher gemerkt.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausböse für diese Schmerzen?
Wie gesagt, früher war das so, dass ich das schon mal so ein bisschen hatte, wenn ich mich doll angestrengt habe.
Also wenn ich schnell eine Treppe hochgelaufen bin oder ein Berg hoch oder wenn ich schnell Fahrrad gefahren bin, mit Gegenwind,
dann habe ich das schon mal gehabt, dass ich so gemerkt habe, ich habe ein bisschen so ein enge Gefühl.
Aber jetzt kann ich nicht sagen, was da der Auslöser war.
Okay, aber diese Schmerzen, also ich meine die früherer Schmerzen, wie haben diese Schmerzen gedauert?
Die haben maximal 30 Minuten gedauert, also ich glaube noch nicht mal so lange.
Wenn man Schmerzen hat, kommt einem das ja immer lange vor.
Waren Sie dafür in Behandlung oder sind Sie ein Arzt besucht?
Ich habe meinen Arzt deswegen nicht besucht, nein.
Ich habe ja eigentlich so gut wie keine Krankheiten, also ich bin ja auch noch jung.
Also insofern bin ich ja jetzt noch nicht beim Arzt gewesen.
Okay, haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen diese früherige Schmerzen hindert oder versteht?
Also was ich gemerkt habe, dass immer wenn ich eingeatmet habe, die Schmerzen stärker waren.
Beim Ausatmen war es dann wieder ein bisschen besser.
Okay, Herr Winter, haben Sie weitere Beschwerden zum Beispiel Übelkeit oder mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Übergeben musste ich mir nicht, aber schlecht war mir schon.
Also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass mein Herz wie verrückt klopft.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, mir läuft das Schweiß dann rücken runter.
Und schlecht war mir wirklich.
Jetzt ist das schon wieder besser, aber das war auch schon so ein Angstgefühl, das ich hatte.
Ich verstehe, Herr Winter, machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Sie sind jetzt bei uns und wir werden Ihnen gleich helfen.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie haben Herzschmerzen?
Gleichzeitig haben Sie Luftnoten oder Atmung?
Ja, ich habe halt so ein Enkelgefühl.
Vielleicht, dass ich nicht richtig einatmen kann.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich fieblich, Herr Winter?
Nee, fieber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, schütteln Frost auf, haben Sie nicht?
Ja, nur dieses kalte Schwitzen, aber schütteln Frost hatte ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Winter, war Ihnen schwindelig oder haben Sie Schweiß vor den Augen bemerkt?
Nee, schwindelig eigentlich, nee, schwindelig war mir nicht.
Und schwarz ist mir auch nicht geworden vor den Augen, nein, nein.
Okay, haben Sie irgendeine chronische Erklanken?
Ja, was ich habe, also seit 20 Jahren eigentlich kann man schon sagen,
habe ich so einen chronischen Husten.
Also, den werde ich irgendwie auch gar nicht so richtig los.
Und naja, ich rauche vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu viel.
Aber also, wenn das zu schlimm wird, dann nehme ich halt ACC, um den Schleim so ein bisschen zu lösen.
Aber das ist das Einzige eigentlich, was ich habe.
Wie ist das ACC?
Wenn ich merke, dass das wieder dollar wird, dann nehme ich das, ja.
Sonst habe ich nix, ich war immer ganz gesund, ja.
Und abgesehen von diesen ASS, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei anderen Medikamenten ein.
Nee, ASS nehme ich nicht, ACC nehme ich.
ACC, entschuldigung.
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie sonst?
Ja, weiß ich, natürlich nimmt man meine Aspirin, wenn man Kopfschmerzen hat oder so.
Aber normal nehme ich eigentlich nix.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Oh ja, das ist aber schon lange her.
Da war ich noch ganz jung.
Da hatte ich einen Unfall und da war der Unterschenkel gebrochen
und da ist operativ versorgt worden.
Wann ist das passiert?
Das ist 15 Jahre her.
Mit Operation.
Haben Sie schlechte Erfahrungen mit dieser Operation gehabt?
Keine schlechten Erfahrungen, nein.
Also das ist alles gut gelaufen, ja.
Okay.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendeine Allergie oder eine Erkranklichkeit in der Kunst?
Ich kann alles essen.
Und ich habe auch nicht irgendwie so etwas wie Heuschnucken oder so,
nee, gar nix.
Also ich bin eigentlich kerngesund, nur jetzt, weil das gefällt mir natürlich nicht.
Okay, Herr Winter, ich möchte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemeinsgesundheitlichen Zustandsfrage.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Och, normalerweise ist er gut, würde ich mal sagen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Seite ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich wiege mich zwar nicht ständig, aber ich glaube, das ist alles so wie immer.
Okay, Herr Winter, ich möchte nur noch Fragen zu Ihrer Person nicht herdaten.
Sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Ich bin 41 und bin geboren am 2. Januar 83.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84.
Und kennen Sie Ihr Abteilengewicht?
Ja, das ist immer so 94,5 kg ungefähr.
Alles klar.
Und Sie haben in der letzten Seite nicht ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ich habe mich jetzt, wie gesagt, nicht jeden Tag gewogen.
Aber die letzte, einmal war ich jetzt in letzter Zeit auf der Waage und da hat sie halt 94,5 gesagt.
Okay.
Wie sieht Ihre Schlafqualität aus?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Eigentlich kann ich meistens gut schlafen, ja, vor allem wenn ich ein Bier getrunken habe oder so,
dann kann ich gut schlafen, ja.
Wie viel Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Beim Schlafen? Einkaufskissen? Mein gutes Kopfkissen, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit Spülgern?
Nein, ich bitte Sie, um Gottes Willen. Nein, nein, das habe ich nie.
Es ist eigentlich immer ganz normal.
Okay.
Müssen Sie nicht in der Nacht häufig zur Toilette oder nicht?
Nein, ich schlafe durch.
Okay.
Leiden Sie untergeschwollene Beine?
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen, aber nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Sortbillen oder müssen Sie häufig Saures aufstoßen?
Höchst selten, wenn ich mal ganz etwas Extremes gegessen habe und vielleicht auch abends spät gegessen habe,
aber so gut wie nie, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie schlechte Mundgeru oder Heißigkeit beim Mal?
Oh, ich hoffe nicht, dass ich schlechte Mundgeru habe. Nein, und Heißer bin ich auch nicht lang.
Manchmal.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, Herr Winter, aber ich muss fragen, wie viel Zigaretzen rauchen Sie täglich und seit wann?
Also, ja, früher habe ich nicht so viel geraucht, aber seit ein paar Jahren,
fährst du seit drei Jahren, rauch ich ein Päckchen am Tag.
Früher habe ich immer nur so eine halbe Packung, aber ja, ich hatte jetzt in letzter Zeit ein bisschen Stress,
meine Ehe ist geschieben und ja, bei der Arbeit ist auch immer viel los.
Also, ja, deswegen habe ich dann irgendwie ein bisschen mehr geraucht.
Aber wie viele Jahre haben Sie halbe Packung geraucht?
Oh, bestimmt, ja, ich habe schon früh angefangen mit dem Rauch, also so 20 Jahre ungefähr.
Mal kurz, mal kurz, alles klar.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also am Wochenende trinke ich schon mal ein paar Bier oder auch mal ein Glas Wein,
wenn es irgendwas zu feiern gibt, aber eigentlich mehr Bier, ja.
Mit Drogen, also da habe ich mich nie darauf eingelassen.
Mit Drogen kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Okay, wir sind zwar durch Herr Winter noch ein paar Fragen.
Ist so in einer familiären Vorgeschichte, sind ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Mein Vater ist früh gestorben.
Der ist sehr früh gestorben.
Der hatte einen Herzinfarkt. Ganz früh.
Okay, wie alt er war?
Er war so Anfang 50, also der ist wirklich sehr früh gestorben.
Okay, und wie ist mit ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter ist grundsätzlich, ja, ist sie noch relativ fit so.
Die hat nur ein bisschen Probleme mit ihren Gelenken.
Und Knochen, die hat so Arthritis in den Gelenken.
Und da hat sie je nachdem, nach Tagesform geht es eh nicht so gut.
Aber eigentlich kommt sie noch gut zurecht.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Okay, alles klar.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie Geschirr sind.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter und die lebt auch bei mir.
Okay, ist sie gesund?
Ja, klar, also gesund ist sie.
Aber das macht für mich natürlich auch nochmal extra Stress.
Dass ich jetzt für das Kind veranbaulich bin.
Ja, denn es ist immer irgendwas und Beruf und Kind unter einen Deckel zu bekommen.
Das ist nicht immer so einfach.
Ja, ich verstehe Herr Winter.
Das ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Und Sie haben schon ein bisschen Sport.
Das sollte ich vielleicht, aber zurzeit komme ich nicht.
Früher habe ich mal ein bisschen Tennis gespielt,
aber das mache ich jetzt nur im Urlaub.
Also regelmäßig mache ich das wirklich nicht.
Manchmal fahre ich mit einem Fahrrad, aber auch jetzt nicht so,
dass ich das sportlich betreibe.
Eigentlich mehr so, um irgendwo hinzukommen.
Okay, Sie haben schon erzählt, dass Sie die Schütze auch bei der Arbeit haben.
Ich bin Speditionskaufmann.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich arbeite in einer großen Spedition.
Und ja, das muss immer alles schnell gehen
und alles muss auf den Punkt klappen.
Und ja, dann fehlt Personal und dann ist ein Auto kaputt.
Ja, da müssen wir immer gucken, dass wir alle Aufträge richtig abwickeln können.
Das ist manchmal schon sehr hektisch.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay Herr Winter, meinerseits habe ich meine alle wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Falls Ihnen noch etwas ein und da haben Sie klagen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt wissen, wie es weitergeht.
Und natürlich will ich auch wissen, ob ich nachher wieder nach Hause kann.
Woher kommt das jetzt, dass es mir einmal so schlecht geht.
Und natürlich will ich zu meiner Tochter zurück.
Und ich muss auch wieder zur Arbeit morgen.
Und ja, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Das ist die Frage.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorge, Sie sind in guter Hände.
Aber das ist zu früh eine diagnostische Sushitelle.
Erstmal muss ich die körperlich untersuchen.
Wir haben schon ein paar Untersuchungen durchgeführt,
aber wir brauchen noch weitere Untersuchungen.
Ein paar Labor-Untersuchungen und weitere operative Untersuchungen.
Aber die Erinnerung ist, dass die Muslime etwas auf die Seite sind.
Ich habe auch noch 5 Fragen.
Okay, ein paar Fragen.
Alles klar.
Gut.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Eine Frage.
Haben Sie gegen Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Schmerz mit der Oda.
Nein, ich habe keinen Schmerz mitgenommen.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestattet, aber nur im Status.
Genau, das ist das einzige.
Im Status sind nicht gefragt.
Ja.
Können wir als Herzgespräch anfangen?
Geht schon?
Nur eine Minute.
Ja, dann machen wir noch.
Ich denke alle Fragen gestattet.
Ich denke, die Partien haben wir schon vielmals gemacht.
Ich habe mich gewundert, so oft war der noch gar nicht dran.
Der war 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, aber auch in verschiedenen Gruppen.
Also in der großen Gruppe war der gar nicht so oft.
Da war der glaube ich nur 3-mal oder so.
Aber es ist natürlich ein Düsseldorfer Fall.
Und insofern ist er schon ein bisschen gebraucht.
Paul Breitner, der Name der Patiente.
Nee, Florian Wilms.
Florian Wilms?
Ja, Florian Wilms.
Okay.
Paul Breitner.
Paul Breitner haben wir auch irgendwo noch im Portfolio.
Ja.
Gut.
Rabia, geht es los?
Ja.
Ja, gut.
Schönen guten Abend Frau Oberalstin.
Wir haben heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Und ich möchte Ihnen unseren Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich.
Unser Patient heißt Frank Winter.
Er ist 41 Jahre alt.
Und 85 Meter groß und 94,5 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hat sich seit 2 Stunden aufgetretenen,
durch den Rest des Sternen, Brustschirmers mit Ausstrahlung in den Arm vor.
Als der Kleidstimme nannte er Karlsruhe,
er hat Angst und Überkeit.
Genau.
Er hat sich seit 6 Jahren auf eine Schmerzskolle getragen.
Aber Schmerzen ist in der Zeit etwas nachgelassen.
Schmerzen hat nachgelassen.
Und aktuell 3 bis 4 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskolle getragen.
Die ähnliche Bescheidwerte haben der Patient trücher.
Aber diese Bescheidwerte waren immer belastungsabhängig.
Und dauerte ungefähr 30 Minuten.
Und deswegen waren unser Patient beim Arzt nicht.
Er hat sich seit 6 Jahren aufgetretenen,
durch den Rest des Sternen, Brustschirmers mit Ausstrahlung in den Arm vor.
Er trinken wöhntlich ein, zwei Flaschen Bier oder Wein, ein Graswein, Gräserwein.
Brockenkonsum wurde verneint.
An der familiären Anamnese, Väterlicherseits Herzinfarkt und Väterlicherseits Arthritis Bekannt.
Sein Vater ist mit 50 Lebensjahr an Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Er hatte keine Schwester.
Herr Frank Winter ist gestiegen, habe eine Tochter und lebe mit ihrer Tochter.
Mit dieser Tochter lebt er zusammen?
Ja, mit dieser Tochter lebt zusammen.
Er arbeitet als Speditionskaufmann und habe viel zu tun.
Er arbeitet auch zu Hause. Er treibe keine regelmäßigen Sport.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Familie?
Aufgrund der anamnestischen Angabe habe ich Verdacht auf Akkuse-Coronasyndrom.
Was könnte es sonst unter Umständen noch sein?
Als Alternative kann ich Gastrosyndrom-Rectus-Krankheit, Pynomotorax oder Autostektion in Betrax.
Ja, gut.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Wir müssen zur weiteren Erklärung.
Sollen wir erst mal den Patienten körperlich untersuchen und Akk-Schreiben?
Sie haben ja schon vor der Notfalluntersuchung gemacht.
Ja, wir haben schon gemacht.
Im Labor sollen wir folgendes überflüten.
Wir haben ein großes Schul- und Entspuntenparameter, CRP, Leber-Niedernmärkte, Herz-Enzyme.
Und vor allen Dingen?
Herz-Enzyme.
Ja, genau. Speziell Troponin.
Ja, Troponin.
Elektrolyte und Gerinnot-Parameter.
Ja, sehr gut.
Gut.
Und, ja, was wären dann die nächsten Schritte?
Was würde man vielleicht diagnostisch noch machen können?
Diagnostisch können wir auch Brontgen-Torax veranlassen, ein-an-Obenen und cardiologisches Ponziensau.
Auf alle Fälle, ne?
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay, gut, ja, dann untersuchen Sie den Herrn Winter und erzählen mir nachher, bitte schön, was rausgekommen ist, wie es ihm geht
und vor allen Dingen auch, was die Laborwerte gesagt haben.
Gut.
Ja, jetzt kommt die Manöverkritik.
Also, du sprichst wunderbar, fließend, schleichen sich ein paar Fehler hinein,
aber also würde ich sagen jetzt ja nicht Sinn entstellen oder so.
Was mich am Anfang ein bisschen verwirrt hat, dass du nicht gleich die Personallien abgefragt hast.
Aber das war wahrscheinlich der Schreck über den Herzinfarkt, ja, dass der seine dramatischen Symptome geschildert hat
und du gesagt hast, ach, müssen wir gleich untersuchen
und vor lauter Schreck hast du gar nicht die Personallien abgefragt.
Ja, das ist natürlich relativ markant, der Patient ist noch sehr jung, der ist 41,
mein klar, der Vater ist mit 50 an einem Infarkt gestorben, da gehen schon die Alarmglocken an, ja, aber, ja,
also wie gesagt, da war ich verwundert und das hast du wahrscheinlich selber gemerkt, oh, da fehlt mir ja noch was
und dann hast du das an untypischer Stelle nachgefragt, ja.
Aber natürlich warst du sehr, sehr vollständig bei der Abfrage der Symptome.
Möglicherweise würde ein Patient, dem es richtig schlecht geht, ein bisschen unwillig reagieren,
wenn er nach so vielen anderen Sachen gefragt wird, ja.
Und dann, oh mein Gott, lassen Sie mich doch in Ruhe mit Stuhlgang und Wasser lassen, ja.
Mir geht schlecht, ja, so, aber, ja, ich denke mal, das ist der, dieser untypischen Situation geschuldet,
dass eben das ganze Fragenprogramm abgewickelt wird.
Ja, das Einzige, wo ich ein richtiges Missverständnis registriere,
du hast gefragt, ob ich Sod brennen habe oder Saros aufstoßen und das hat der Patient eigentlich verneint.
Und du hast es aber, ja, oberärztlich, der hat Sod brennen, ja.
Also ich, mal alles Patient, habe ich gesagt, nö, das habe ich eigentlich nicht, ja.
Wobei das eben noch so ein Punkt in der Reihe war,
mein Gott, was will sie denn noch alles wissen, ja.
Ich habe doch solche, solche Schmerzen und dieses enge Gefühl und mir geht es doch so schlecht, ja.
Ja, die Übelkeit ist so ein bisschen im Arztbericht untergegangen,
Übelkeit ohne, ohne Immersis, ne.
Also er hat sich nicht übergeben, aber ihm ist wahnsinnig schlecht gewesen, ja.
Gut, ja, ansonsten würde ich aber sagen, war das, war das vollständig
und natürlich auch die ganzen Schritte, was man hinterher machen kann
und was zu tun ist vollständig.
Die, natürlich war auch diese Reaktion genau richtig unterbrechen
für die Vitalparameter-Untersuchung.
Nur, das ist natürlich auch immer schwierig, nachher ohne Werte eigentlich weiterzusprechen, ja.
Die Werte würden ja irgendwas, was ich, das EKG gibt ja irgendein Befund her.
Gerade wenn der wirklich was hat, gibt das EKG ja irgendwas, ja, das zeigt ja irgendwas
und das ist natürlich jetzt in dieser Simulation untypisch,
aber da muss man halt irgendwo sich durchschummeln, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das in der Prüfung ist.
Ob die dann tatsächlich irgendwelche Daten einem geben oder irgendein EKG-Ausdruck?
Nein, aber unsere Reaktion ist, in der Zwischenzeit können wir unser Gespräch vorsetzen.
Ah, okay, ja, in der Zwischenzeit, ja, aber ja nicht mehr zu schicken.
Ja, in der Zwischenzeit können wir unser Gespräch vorsetzen.
Na ja, gut, ja.
Aber nachher gibt man das ja nochmal an und sagt, ja, was machen wir,
körperliche Untersuchungen und nochmal Vitalparameter-Checken, klar.
Und vielleicht macht man dann auch noch ein Kontroll-EKG, ne?
Ja, Herzultraschall wäre vielleicht noch so eine Sache, aber da hast du dich ja fein rausgehalten,
indem die sagt, machen kardiologische Konzine.
Ja, sollen die mal gucken, wie sie damit gelahe kommen, ja.
Ich rufe dann einfach Dr. Gündes an und dann kommt er.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ich denke mal, dass du sprachlich eigentlich wirklich wenig, wenig Probleme hast
und schlüssig argumentieren kannst und eben auch gut, ja, ich freue mich ja immer,
auch wenn ich als Patient mit Namen angesprochen werde.
Und auch, das ist mir jetzt auch positiv aufgefallen, dass du zum Beispiel,
sie haben ja schon erwähnt, dass sie rauchen, wie viele Zigaretten rauchen sie denn, ja?
Oder sie haben erwähnt, dass sie geschieden sind, wie ist denn sonst ihre Lebenssituation, ja?
Also du hast praktisch dem Patienten das Gefühl gegeben, ich habe zugehört, was sie sagen.
Ja, und das ist einfach etwas Wichtiges.
Wenn jemand ja nur schematisch seine Sachen runterrasselt und ja, was ich mich jetzt gerade,
was ich nicht gefragt habe, nehme ich auch nicht wahr, ne?
Dann fragt man das hinterher noch mal und dann sagt er, habe ich ihn doch schon gesagt, ne?
Und das ist natürlich super, wenn du das schaffst in der Prüfungssituation,
eben auch noch so diese Umsicht zu haben, sie haben schon erwähnt, das, ne?
Und das dann noch zu verarbeiten in irgendeiner Frage.
Super. Ja. Also ich denke vor dem 19. August musst du keine Angst haben, ja?
Und ja, natürlich halten wir daum. Ja, jetzt kommt die traurige Botschaft an alle.
Ich bin jetzt ein paar Wochen weg, ja? Ich hoffe, es ist nicht...